se procurer de l'alcool pour un mineur
rien de plus facile
nous avons envoyé fanfan 9 en acheter
des bières dans un supermarché à paris
avec l'autorisation de ses parents
caméras et micros cachés il suffit de
payer et fanfan comme un personnage de
bande dessinée peut emporter ses bières
à la maison ou bien les déboires avec
ses copains car il existe des enfants de
8 ans alcoolique
ceux là ont entre 12 et 16 ans ils
boivent régulièrement depuis trois
années
pas des voyous pas des délinquants
garçons de milieux modestes mais pas
déshériter la bière ou le vin valent
moins cher que le jus de fruits et les
sodas
il utilise l'alcool pourrait être cassé
comme ils disent comme une drogue dure
mais c'est légal
déjà dix ou quinze bières par jour où
autant de pastis souvent tout commence
en famille les copains
avec les copains on apprécie la voir et
qui de plus en plus maintenant on est
comme ça tu te sens bien quoi bah ouais
je change de cible ou la fin je suis un
peu speed
[Applaudissements]
et
et quand tu bois tu te sens peu mieux on
plus fort je me sens bien
julie bihar est
je pense à rien qu'on est ensemble quand
on boit on y loue et on est bien
sensible est ensemble quoi est ce que
les gens m'emmerdait avant que je boive
je le dis ça m'emmerdait les genres tout
le monde m'emmerdait j'm'en enfin plus
maintenant je sais pas c'est cool c'est
pareil c'est vrai on voit pas la vie
pareille trouble leur école c'est la rue
et pour fumer du cannabis ou pourboire
il faut de l'argent
cet argent il le vol dans le
portefeuille des parents ivre il croit
pouvoir se dépasser
quand on est complètement saoul
communion de bourg et on a plus de
courage pour potes c'est peut-être une
sorte de truc pour se cacher derrière
l'alcool pour faire nos deux conneries
titane a qualifié d' avis qui la
qualifierait dacoury vous mourrez
personnellement je m'éclate bien je suis
content tu faire de moi je prendrai ma
personne
ces adolescents ne croient plus en
l'avenir
persuadé que déjà ils ont perdu toutes
leurs chances mais seuls agen ils
redeviennent des enfants un rendez vous
manqué avec les parents qu'est ce que tu
as fait famille pourrait faire pour
t'aider
le comprendre par les autres avec moi
son patient il cesse beaucoup qu'est ce
que tu fous là qui te dit j'aimerais
pouvoir discuter avec maintenant j'ai
discuté de quoi de tout la vie des gens
toute la drogue
la joie de tous moi je me sentirai mieux
déjà
[Musique]